ja ich habe mich heute auf gericht über
dorothea dorothee bär ist ja die digital
beauftragte der bundesregierung sich er
redet gerne über flug taxis macht kecke
posts auf insgesamt und ist vor allen
dingen eine glühende verehrerin von
markus söder in dem csu chef und
ministerpräsidenten der des freistaats
bayern seit heute ist dorothee der kurz
genannt doro aber auch mitglied sind es
im team lasche diesem achtköpfigen
gremium dass angesichts dramatisch
schlechter umfragewerte retten soll was
noch zu retten ist ausgerechnet dorothea
mag man denken denn sie ist die frau die
noch von wenigen wochen ist das dürfen
wir dann herrn millionen-publikum
meischberger war das gesagt hat warum
armin laschet auf gar keinen fall
bundeskanzler werden soll werden darf
und warum es markus söder unbedingt
werden muss
dorothee bär ist die frau auch in dieser
sendung die abstimmung im cdu-präsidium
also dem höchsten parteigremium der cdu
zu einer hinterzimmer diskussion
deklariert hat und gesagt hat das darf
gar nicht sein aber wissen sie was mich
am meisten aufregt drohte bär hatte ja
recht damals und jetzt distanzieren sich
sogar diejenigen von armin laschet ihnen
dann damals aufs heutige schild gehoben
haben aufgang schäuble grummelt im
hintergrund und jemand wie der hessische
ministerpräsident volker bouffier sagt
in der faz gerade gestern das haben wir
uns alles anders vorgestellt
also wer was macht sie hören wir von ihr
der aufrechten streiterin von markus
söder jetzt angesichts dramatisch
schlechter umfragewerte ich hatte recht
markus söder hätte es werden machen
machen sollen nach dem motto ich war
diejenige die richtig gelegen hat nichts
nada nennt im gegenteil jetzt steht sie
da schwingt ihr fähnchen sagt nette
sachen über armin laschet ins mikrofon
das neue fahne von 100 aber die europäer
wären nicht dort auf dieser bühne wenn
markus söder ihr dafür nicht ihr platze
sein go gegeben hätte deswegen habe ich
ein verdacht vielleicht ist der eintritt
von touropa ins team von armin laschet
so etwas wie die heimliche rache seiten
des größten konkurrenten und busselt
[Applaus]
ja also ich bin da ziemlich überrascht
als ich meine das team von armin laschet
versprühte richtig aufbruch
und mit dorothee bär noch mehr um das
mal stück was sich darzustellen ich
finde deutschland ist nach wie vor eine
digitale wüste und nach zwölf jahren csu
regierung
regierungsverantwortung das thema
digitalisierung
schäme ich mich dafür also ich bin
wirklich ich habe es satt steige münchen
im hauptbahnhof im zug ein um wo auch
immer hin zu fahren ich habe keinen
handyempfang ich habe keinen wlan ich
habe keinen datentransfer und was hat
ihnen jahren getan nix wir sind in der
aktuellen pisa-studie hinter moldawien
was digitalisierung angeht
markus söder und auch die csu sie
schmücken sich doch so gern immer mit
ihren rankings wie toll bayern da steht
aber wenn wir auf bundesebene anschauen
was diese parteien den letzten zwölf
jahren eingestellt hat dann bin ich
wirklich fassungslos
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
bin der meinung das ist immer
digitalisierung wirklich jetzt mal
langsam mal ernsthaft angegangen werden
muss und sagt gerhard schröder 2001
wurde gesagt in der legislaturperiode
noch werden die menschen e governance
haben das heißt wir werden uns an oder
ummelden können fahrzeuge zu lassen
können ausweis neu beantragen und alles
digital ich kann heute in münchen einen
termin online beantragen muss aber
persönlich hingehen irgendwie drei
monate später und dort warten bis ich
dann ins zimmer ag oder wieder
wartezeiten oder ein zimmer gehen also
das heißt nicht nichts getan in den
letzten 20 jahren es ist lächerlich also
die diskrepanz zwischen sonntagsreden
und realität ist so groß in deutschland
und ich frage mich wenn armin laschet
wirklich damit beeindrucken wollte
also ich muss hinzufügen wir sind in
deutschland digitales entwicklungsland
ja ich sehe es aus meinem eigenen
unternehmer alltag digitale verwaltung
fehlanzeige von seiten der jungen
unternehmer appellieren wir schon die
ganze zeit an die politik was du gerade
erwähnt hast wir brauchen hier eine
digitale infrastruktur das fehlt alles
was ich natürlich vermisst habe wenn ich
jetzt auf das letzte tv tree l schaue da
war ja digitalisierung 0 thema keiner
der kanzlerkandidaten hat das thema
digitalisierung angesprochen jetzt muss
ich sagen war ich dann doch überrascht
heute mit dem zukunftsteam von armin
laschet muss ich sagen dass wenigstens
da jemand mit drin ist er mit dem thema
digitalisierung verbunden wird das stb
und ich würde mir wirklich wünschen dass
das jetzt fahrt aufnimmt und ich kann
auch zu dem team von armin laschet kurz
noch einen satz hinzu ich muss sagen ich
war wirklich überrascht und und es ist
für mich jetzt so ein laschet team mit
acht samurai also hat sich jetzt ein
kämpfer team aufgestellt ich finde es
gut dass er verstanden hat dass er ein
team braucht wenn wir jetzt zu olaf
scholz gucken als kanzlerkandidat ist
eine one man show also von daher schon
mal sehr positiv gut aufgestellt wie ich
finde wir sollten jetzt nicht da voll
mit dem hammer drauf hauen er hat
verschiedene themenbereiche den
wirtschaftsmann friedrich merz er hat
georgia low mit dabei als unternehmer
endlich kommt da auch
wirtschaftskompetenz mit rein was wir
jetzt auch so dringend brauchen nach
corona und aber lange tradition sagte
weiter so und das ist doch fatal aber
ich habe eine eine umfrage die umfang
sie meist nicht wer am tisch würde denn
sagen dorothee bär also wenn ich jetzt
digital ein digital mensch brauche wenn
er als experte dorothee bär ich muss
ganz klar sagen dorothee bär hätte ich
niemals für ich weiß sie ist ich weiß
warum sie da drin sitzt aber wer von
unserem tisch bitten ist sie für dich
digital experten also würdest du sagen
neben ihrem aktuell ist sie auch border
als ich würde sie an den fakten messen
und sie hat die letzten dreieinhalb
jahre zeigen können was sie kann und die
fakten sind nun einmal musst du sie
hättest du sie einander schnittstelle
reingenommen also ich muss sagen es war
natürlich ist auch eine strategische
entscheidung sie ist gut vernetzt die
alle in sicherheit sie kennt
digitalisierung nicht nur vom hörensagen
würde ich sagen sie kennt sich bei den
ganzen themen social media twitter kennt
sich gut aus
natürlich jetzt wenn man schauen dass
hans-jürgen ja ja also von daher klar es
hat nicht alles so gut geklappt aber ich
würde auch noch mal eine zweite chance
geben dass sie da ist ein turbo star
models ja ich glaube auf instagram ist
sehr glaubwürdig in der realpolitik er
nicht sie beschäftigt sich seit dem
eintritt in den bundestag mit diesem
thema sie hat aber nichts zustande
gebracht und ich frage mich wenn das das
team zukunft ist wo ist denn das team
gegen bar wo ist denn ein peter altmaier
wo ist einsparen was macht annegret
kramp karrenbauer spielen die nach der
wahl alle keine rolle mehr was ist denn
das für ein team das der steht was sind
die aufgabenbereiche bearbeiten sollen
die minister werden sollen die in einem
zirkel politik formulierende eine tritt
an in spandau oder mehr berichte gesehen
also das war comedy pur und insofern
frage ich mich wirklich wofür stehen die
also welche bereiche stehen diese leute
heute präsentiert worden sollen die
ministrabel sein oder was ist das und
die bebauung ist ja ich glaube sie sind
mit ihrer einschätzung der morgen der
kommentierung relativ allein es ist
natürlich gut wenn wir auch mal
gegenstimme haben wir das feiern dass
sie da machen aber so gut kam das heute
nicht an sie meinen jetzt das team zu
kultivieren armin laschet ich muss sagen
ich finde es schon gut dass sein team
sich überhaupt aufgestellt hat weil wie
gesagt irgendwann über den
kanzlerkandidaten wie bei olaf scholz
wissen wir jetzt nicht was danach kommen
[Musik]